but those interactions i think
are human i mean that's part of life so
it is scary taking away everything how
long till we're not [ __ ]
that's coming too yeah then there's
gonna have two two types of people are
you
[ __ ] in real life are you a digital [ __ ]
person i'm a digital i like real [ __ ]
sorry we can't date that's coming well
there's also the the reproduction side
of sex which is like with genetic
engineering
you'll be able to specify a little bit
of details
i talked to uh jamie martial about that
like where you can
um
specify like
what you know uh
it'll start with like i want my child
not to have
like a high likelihood of diabetes or
something like that and then you get to
specify like intelligence you just get
to specify those kinds of parameters
until
you're like
basically trying to create a perfect
human and you lose some of the magic of
the flaws that make us who we are yes
and you know i
i'm pretty sure in the full lineup of
humans
like the so
let me uh give you some information
i'm sure you researched uh this
thoroughly but
uh um uh a male of the human species of
the homo sapien
uh produces 500 billion
sperm cells in a lifetime
so that's all
uh some more than others
that's all
uniquely genetically unique humans that
you could produce so even across those
500 billion you can select
and so i mean like abort some
or no you can choose which of them you
want i mean just imagine all the genetic
possibilities that are there like all
the possible like you won
the race
yes
uh
shocking this is yeah this is the ball
the 500 billion you have to imagine what
the competition was oh just tards all
day long handicapped
well so it's not actually the the
fastest sperm or like it it's i think a
lot of his timing and luck
uh what it seems like there's actual
papers on this and i've actually been
reading them i hope so so it's not just
like the fastest sperm to the egg okay
there's a timing thing
so you were just lucky all right i i
believe that
so it's interesting to think about like
once you're able to specify
some parameters of what your child is
like
how that changes the nature of um
even just like
the intimacy of two humans getting
together
and making
creating together a child yeah i mean it
changes it it's it's almost like uh i
don't know it becomes like a factory
line of some kind
if you don't meet naturally yeah if you
don't mean natural
and then you don't and you get you get
to optimize your child
then it's yeah
then it's something like you have to
consider utilitarian type of things like
what's good for society and it'll
probably be regulation about what kind
of children you can have or not like
your child cannot have an iq below this
or above us or something like that
your child cannot we already kind of do
that we know
vip clubs like hey you're kind of ugly
or women go hey he's not tall enough we
kind of do it a little yeah especially
sexually
yeah we do can't get on the roller
coaster if you're this short whatever it
is you know we do it in some capacity
but here this would be like
fully transparent
and to a degree that uh it's hard to
imagine like with the way we currently
do it you can at least get around it yes
you can at least like trick your way
onto the roller coaster even if you're
short right or the fat guy can get rich
so you can get laid you know there's
other ways
you